des géants blancs dans le ciel gris à
Magny-les-Hameaux c'était l'animation
parvient en fait beaucoup de monde comme
tous les ans des ateliers de dégustation
jeux en bois ou décoration ici il s'agit
de donner une autre vie au bonnet rouge
joyeux Noël ça fait ça comment
avec des paillettes et des feutres je
suis infidèle je viens tous les ans à la
fête rien que pour les gamins etc et
plus je trouve que ça un petit moment
convivial au niveau toute la ville et
puis tous les hameaux ça nous permet
tous de nous retrouver
dans la salle du conseil municipal ce
jour-là pas d'élus mais de drôle de
personnages ce sont des marionnettes
Jeanne et plasticienne c'est elle qui
les conçoit visite guidée avec les
enfants
les marionnettes sont en matériau de
récupération et cela ne laisse pas
indifférent j'aime beaucoup la
composition des marionnettes qui décèle
une un esprit de création absolument
extraordinaire et
très expressif tout en étant un petit
peu abstrait tu trouves qu'il y a de la
beauté dans l'objet dans l'objet voilà
dans l'objet usuel et j'ai envie de le
transformer voilà pourquoi on va dire
c'est une des premières voilà et puis
c'est parce que c'est du matériel qu'on
trouve aussi facilement les
marionnettistes ont des petits budgets
donc voilà ils font aussi avec ce qu'ils
ont outre l'esthétique on pouvait aussi
les saisir et les manipuler pour les
enfants c'est vraiment très plaisant de
pouvoir utiliser les marionnettes de
pouvoir voir comment ça marche et puis
c'est vachement important par rapport à
la marionnette parce que sinon si on
regarde une exposition de Marinette sans
les manipuler ça reste des sculptures et
la marionnette la particularité c'est
que ce sont des sculptures en mouvement
donc il faut leur donner le mouvement
bonjour je m'appelle Alfred
c'est comme si c'était nous mais on
faisait enfin
je sais pas par exemple c'est la
marionnette du Président on peut faire
n'importe quoi avec c'est comme du
théâtre voilà c'est du théâtre on avait
des marionnettes
les marionnettes étaient partout ce
samedi à Manille ou presque